let's dig into some stories the
backstory of course on Donald Trump's
Obama wiretapped me thing is that Donald
Trump sent a series of tweets several
weeks ago saying that President Obama
had had his wires tapped in Trump Tower
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah increasingly we
know that this isn't true and Sean
Spicer argued within a 48-hour period
late last week that both Donald Trump
didn't literally mean wiretapped and
that Donald Trump stands the stand by
the tweets despite there being no
evidence to suggest that he was right
that Obama wiretapped him a review has
now been done of Justice Department
documents regarding the allegations and
the Republican House Intelligence
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez has
confirmed that there exists no evidence
that Trump Tower was wired tapped
nevermind by President Obama or someone
acting under Obama's instruction
Republicans and Democrats have both said
we've seen nothing from the intelligence
agencies suggesting that Trump Tower was
wire tapped just before today's show I
was listening to a head of the NSA Mike
Rogers and FBI director James Comey
saying we have no evidence that would
indicate that Trump Tower was watt wire
tapped and Donald Trump bizarrely just
refusing to admit that he's wrong keeps
making these strange allusions to future
information that will come out here's a
short clip from his interview on Fox
News with Tucker Carlson a few days ago
but we will be submitting certain things
and I will be perhaps speaking about
this next week but it's right now before
the committee and I think I want to
leave it to have a lot of confidence I
not wait to tweet about it until you can
prove it because you value your words
when you can't provide them because the
New York Times wrote about it not that I
respect the New York Times I call it the
failing New York Times but they did
write on January 20th using the word
wiretap so can we trust the New York
Times or not I guess only when you agree
with it and then Donald Trump predicted
the following but wiretap covers a lot
of different things I think you're going
to find some very interesting items
coming to the forefront over the next
two weeks right well here's what no one
is talking about
fiscal conservatives should be furious
about this they are cheerleading the
cutting off of tiny spending on social
programs and Trump's budget that are
actually useful to many people but
they're silent about the taxpayer money
that's going into investigations and
panels and hearings of bogus allegations
that the president makes on Twitter it's
not really fiscally conservative is it
no not at all I mean you should at least
have some sort of basis for your
investigation it seems like when he
released those series of tweets that he
was privy to something going on or maybe
someone in the intelligence community
said that maybe your wires were tapped
by President Obama I would hope you
would hope I guess it was just based off
an article that was six weeks old at the
time yes and are also if you actually
looked at the different articles that
could have been the catalyst for Trump's
tweet there was like a Breitbart article
which cited another article which was
anonymously sourced and of course Donald
Trump is against the anonymous sourcing
of articles and media as he famously
infamously now said at a CPAC speech now
that it's abundantly clear that the
entire Obama wiretap me thing is without
evidence can we get back to the
corruption and the Russian connections
the disastrous budget the conflicts of
interest the newly blocked second travel
ban the disastrous American Health Care
Act
I checked Fox news.com no report about
the fact that intelligence agencies are
saying yes there's no evidence for this
I checked Breitbart comm when this broke
no report about the fact that
intelligence agencies are saying there's
absolutely nothing nothing at all to
support Donald Trump's allegation the
trumpet's may never learn that this was
a completely without evidence allegation
because the right-wing propaganda news
websites aren't mentioning that
intelligence agencies are saying there's
enough nothing to believe here but I
guess in that case Trump succeeds
because that's the whole reason why he
made up this controversy was to in part
distract from the Russia story to go on
offense at this point I don't even know
there's so many scandals it's not clear
what is meant to distract from which
other disastrous thing that's going on
and this is having an impact on Trump's
approval rating I want to talk about
that next